[موسيقى]
تجربه الكشري في مصر طبق الكشري في مصر
غير اي طبق ثاني المصريين بياكلوا طول
الوقت بيطبخوه باكثر من طريقه وبيحبوه حب
مش عادي
[موسيقى]
الفرق ما بين الكشري العادي او التقليدي
في مصر وبين الكشري الاسكندراني لانه
الكشري الاسكندريه
وعلى فكره بالمناسبه الكشري الاسكندراني
هو الاقرب للكشري الهندي اللي احنا هنعرف
مكوناته في الجزء الثاني
[موسيقى]
تجربه الكشري في الهند مع صديقي
هو اسهل طبقه الطهي بالنسبه لامي نحن نضيف
له الشطه وبهارات المثله لهم كشري بعض
الزيت ويقدمون معه الخيار والخبز الرفيع
[موسيقى]
الكشري وصل
وتوابل كثير جدا حاره
والخبز الرفيع
ين
وان انت تجرب الاطباء في بلدك او
التقليديه في بلدك ثانيه دي حاجه ممتعه
جدا بس هي في الهند صعبه عشان حراق شويه
اصل الطبق ايه اللي هو مصري
الموضوع ده الحقيقه بس الاكيد ان الكشري
هو حاجه اساسيه في الثقافتين البلدين
الشعبين بياكلوه طول الوقت كل المواسم
واكله شعبيه بالنسبه للبلدين اكله محببه
جدا بالنسبه للبلدين اكله مشبعه ثمنها مش
غالي وفي نفس الوقت بتدفي وطعمها حلو
وغنيه فيتامينات ومعادن كثير جدا
[موسيقى]